It's an important day for Colombia...
...as the Latin American country's first ever left-wing president...
...Gustavo Petro is inaugurated.
From the early hours of Sunday,...
...people began arriving in the capital...
...from all regions of the country for the event.
Today is a historic day for our beloved country, Colombia,...
...because for the first time in 200 years,...
...a ruler who was elected by the people, for the people, takes office.
As a former senator and mayor of Bogota,...
...he is promising a more inclusive government.
He wants to address inequality, offer free education,...
...improve the health care system,...
...and to phase out Colombia's reliance on fossil fuel extraction.
To pay for these ambitious measures, he's promising tax reforms.
But Mr. Petro is also a former left-wing guerrilla leader,...
...and as president, says he will fully implement a peace deal...
...signed with the FARC rebel group in 2016,...
...a deal that stalled...
...under the administration of outgoing leader Ivan Duque.